[Music]
hey Johnny
hey this is Johnny Rome hi he's Asian
we're gonna watch some men react today
of course to bat a great Hollywood
Stuntz and I saw on the thumbnail there
was some martial arts and some Donnie
Yen do you know him Donnie Yen he's it
men right yeah but I was asking are you
like you know him personally
oh yeah we share the same masseuse every
video needs to have a theme of massaging
with me and Asian well when we get to
react to a BTS video oh yeah cuz you're
Korean
yeah do you know them I know of them
Johnny you're letting me down no I'm
sorry all right
all jokes aside you seen Carter true I
love quarter crew but you haven't seen
this video right I've seen this specific
line god I didn't want you to lie you're
terrible liar ninety-nine percent of the
videos we cover we've already seen
multiple this whole thing acting Oh
acting part of acting this reactive a
corner crew is one of my favorite
channels and yeah I go out looking at
the first immature Sammo hung I watched
so many of his movies growing up it's
still badass he isn't at man - he
actually directed the action oh cool
I've seen it Man 1 in it Man 4 are you
disappointed
samo versus Donnie
[Music]
I love that what's crazy me too
[Laughter]
Wow
really what that's weird
they actually built hell yeah actually
like this one more than the first one
that's not give opinions he linked up
with and made the ground so cool round
is super soft and then they put the
overlay of the grass then we're up to
the drops they would have like maybe
three or four guys on a bus so we were
literally at the mercy of them
communicating with each other and that's
I had no I thought that was yeah
[Music]
these are so good you see in this I know
they what they improvise and the
improvise on fighting what woman's crack
OH
[Music]
god oh my god a little bit oh my god
something's coming at the I know I was
just like an intricate little dance
Oh
getting knowledge from watching the
general public is able to look at a
ground game he'll be like oh he's going
for something I know that there's work
happening which is why chocolate is so
because you get to see the grappling
aspect and honestly that's a lot easier
the teacher actor I want to do only
grappling oh dear love that's like other
stuff I'd like to see us talk about this
channel losing requests out in the
hospital oh we read them all it's great
feedback resurrection
every see the spice is dope oh my god I
love this so much safety oh damn it oh
yeah it's insane
yes thanks to referencing freakin source
in order for the quality you have to
really spend so if I see news always you
choose the sequence or you're just going
to shoot this one moment what you're
wondering what you're going to use
yeah or did you like policies you
covered the entire fight Oh sounds like
a [ __ ] probably do you watch things oh
yeah it seemed like two episodes
daredevil
[Laughter]
awesome cool sorry to disappoint you
with my knowledge is really good I
here's what I mainly got from this video
Donnie Yen is nuts
Johnny doe he is crazy he's an insane
guy boys really love Donnie yen's work
boys really admire the guy a hell of a
lot he hasn't done a lot of American
work but he's pretty freakin famous over
yeah no I mean rogue one certainly
helped a lot but yeah the it man
franchise is pretty popular at least in
LA yeah I work at am seeing it man four
is currently showing and it's been
selling out like it man 4 is busy yeah
Donnie yen's career's insane but then
looking at so much of what they talked
about here with with him that comment
about we call that stupid this is like
too ridiculous but there were things
here that I just had never even heard of
that you can do before that alleyway
fight which is a really popular fight
and I've seen that sequence a few times
and that to hear that they just
improvised yeah what do you mean you
improvise the fight
but maybe a second they said that yeah
wait did you properly put that in the
right terms but apparently they
improvised the fight that's super hater
so we were way too safe about those
things like we were talking about the
stuntman Donnie Yen just being like I'll
pay you next Star Wars universe there's
the thing that Jackie Chan has you know
often complained about the differences
between filming in the States and then
filming in Hong Kong or China because
they're a lot more loose plain and
simple out here we are so much more we
care a lot about safety you know
insurance is all those things are a lot
more prevalent or they're at they can
just easily how do you just say
something like that and then do the most
good knock him out that's the craziest
thing I've heard Donnie yen's nuts you
gotta love him for it no wonder his
fight scenes are so freakin awesome
mm-hmm
so awesome dude you gotta respect your
Harry Hey
well I'm Korean then you know we got
parasites
[Music]
Wow well told stories about socialism in
class what about some badass know one
thing I really wanted to say super
quickly about Porter's videos in general
these ones I love their uses of clips
unlike losing the behind-the-scenes
videos Gregory
and like the the random clips - I'm sad
personified jokes - just just make jokes
like blades are cool yeah they didn't do
that as much Fila that's maybe something
some implements Ian lately cuz yeah I
didn't notice it like using It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia blades of glory
let you talk to Popeye just these random
reference points to it yeah it's like
the humor and the jokes and the visuals
that's just super what it is so
entertaining LT had they're great guys
I've met a few of them before I haven't
you were a dick collider that's true
screen junkies needed and taken probably
and also talking about guardians to
galaxy that famous shot were they're all
going up towards the camera I had no
clue that that was actual real stuntmen
I thought it might have been like a wire
effect
yeah of them hanging and then they just
amplified it but then they were showing
this behind-the-scenes footage the core
creatures really opened my eyes to the
amount of stuff net worth that goes into
Marvel because so much of the time i io
honestly sometimes candy oh yeah exactly
and then no one I saw like so much
endgame or infinity war behind the
scenes they have like giant green screen
rooms and they added in most of it yeah
and then when they're showing guardians
I was really impressed by how much they
built with the ground oh yeah I'm the
stunt man go up and down like that that
was really awesome James Gunn knows how
to run a fun set I know and it also
makes great tweets come on stuff so
funny let's bring those back up Samwell
Hong as a guy grew up on
literally I grew up on him oh he went to
the same school as Jackie Chan Lee these
were literally like pretty much brothers
growing actually did get a longer own
out and then he had an injury he gained
a lot of weight while he was recovering
but he was still able to do all the
crazy stuff he could like do the flips
did the stunt suits and he managed to
imagine he became a wonderful action
director and he managed to make a career
for himself embracing kind of this
heavyset image it's like he's overweight
really overweight but he can also do the
flips and the kick yeah things you know
that's not really common and I hide
having him out here in the states for a
while he did a show called martial law
on CBS nobody sounds like a very CBS
show to me he's not a good show
sorry CBS still he's I wish more people
were aware of his talent yeah hmm you
like being this close I do your Musk you
should sell your Musk unlike what's a
musk like your scent you should sell
your scent on uh Wow all right guys well
if you haven't done so make sure to
subscribe to corger crew you can
subscribe that you know what to do
notification bells yada yada yada Johnny
has his own channel I'll watch a video
later of his a good video you said you
saw a video of mine before
oh that's right I definitely lied oh
come on skin there's a poetry one like I
said it makes it great this whole job is
like 99% I'd like to end this with a
patron of the day shout out to a man
named JT you see I am half asian myself
that's why I think I got a pass and
making some Asian jokes at a full Asian
guy I'm actually half asian too
what what no you're ruining this JT is
full Japanese though Oh sick I mean when
you think about it you combine a half
Filipino with a half Korean you get a
Japanese guy
essentially yeah right that's the way
math works it's the way biology or teeth
so JT you are the the product of Johnny
and I and you're welcome you're welcome
and JT actually just went to a film
festival where he spent like $400 what
film festival something in Hawaii I got
to see John Woo talked another Asian guy
look at this oh wait John Woo that's
like wait yeah man
no your Asian people aquafina just won a
Golden Globe and JD hit me up crying
about it I love that movie
that's my favorite movie you texting me
about it I did I told you see it Greg
and you stand then three days later you
said hey you want to call my channel I
said most of its not in English no
thanks and then I watched parasite
that's right even though it's a USA made
a film that says something the Golden
Globes stink obsessed me sorry what's
happened to my hair